mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour et bien encore une mauvaise
nouvelle ce matin il ya eu de nouveau
une avalanche en montagne et cette fois
ci en suisse
elle aurait fait une trentaine de morts
ou disparus
le mauvais temps provoquent d'autres par
des inondations dans presque toute la
moitié nord de la france et nous allons
voir tout cela dans un instant mais
d'abord un coup d'oeil vers les états
unis il est 7 heures du matin le soleil
n'est donc pas encore levé à camp david
la résidence campagnarde des présidents
américains mise à la disposition du
président de la république et madame
georges pompidou
pour leur première nuit aux états unis
c'est dire que la première journée de la
visite officielle de monsieur pompidou
aux états unis n'est pas encore commencé
elle commencera en fait à 4h30 cet après
midi heure française c'est-à-dire 10h30
du matin à washington par la première
entrevue entre les présidents nixon et
pompidou
elle se poursuivra par un déjeuner
offert par l'association des
journalistes américains et ce sera la
première dure épreuve pour monsieur
pompidou car nos confrères
d'outre-atlantique ne sont pas
particulièrement tendre quand il
interviewe des hommes politiques ce soir
grande réception à la maison blanche
c'est le président nixon on dînera au
son d'une musique jouée par un orchestre
de mérite
voilà donc le programme de la journée du
président pompidou
je vous propose maintenant un retour en
arrière c'était à 10 heures 10 heures du
soir hier quatre heures de l'après-midi
à washington et le dc-8 présidentielle
venait tout juste de se poser
il fait beau et froid il est 15h55 heure
locale soit à 21h55 heure de paris le
dc-8 présidentielle se posent à la base
militaire d'un job bien qu'aucune
cérémonie ne soit prévu à l'arrivée car
la visite officielle ne commence que
mardi matin le vice président des états
unis monsieur spiro agnew est chargé par
le président nixon d'accueillir monsieur
et madame pompidou
le président de la république ne passera
qu'une dizaine de minutes sur le terrain
où il va saluer les personnalités
américaines et françaises dans le spiro
agnew comme on vient de le dire
et monsieur emile moche pas cher chef du
protocole à la maison blanche
et monsieur charles lui c'est
ambassadeur de france à washington l'un
et l'autre devant d'ailleurs accompagné
le président pendant toute la durée de
la visite aux états unis
le président de la république et madame
pompidou se sont ensuite rendus en
hélicoptère au camp david résidences
privées des présidents américains
environ 80 km de washington
c'est également en hélicoptère que
monsieur pompidou doit aujourd'hui se
rendre du camp david à la maison blanche
où il aura commencé un premier entretien
politique d'une heure d'une heure et
demie pardon avec le président nixon
hier alors que l'avion présidentiel
étaient encore au dessus de l'atlantique
notre envoyé spécial bernard folker
assistait lui à washington à une
manifestation de quelques milliers de
citoyens juifs américains hostiles à la
politique française à l'égard d'israël
ici washington nous nous trouvons devant
la maison blanche
et vous allez avoir tout de suite un
avant goût de ce qui attend le président
pompidou
durant son voyage aux etats unis un
exemple un voyage qui n'est pas encore
commencé réellement puisque le président
pompidou n'a pas encore quitté son avion
pour arriver ici à washington
il sera là dans quelques heures
seulement mais il ya eu déjà ce matin
depuis 11 heures une manifestation qui a
rassemblé plusieurs milliers de juifs de
washington une manifestation contre la
politique française au proche orient un
prospectus un tract a été distribué à
cette occasion on demande aux
participants de le signer de l'envoyer à
l'ambassade de france à l'intention du
président pompidou et ce tract dit
notamment j'élève ma voix pour condamner
vigoureusement la politique anti
israélienne et pro arabe du gouvernement
français je condamne la vente des jets à
la libye et je condamne le refus de la
france de vendre les 50 avions mirage
que qu'israël a payé 2 refuse de les
pendre à israël alors donc un exemple de
ce qui attend je crois le président
pompidou
tout au long de son voyage des
etats-unis et notamment à chicago à new
york où l'on s'attend qu'il y aura les
manifestation beaucoup plus importante
que celle ci que le président n'a
d'ailleurs même pas
tenace et bias
quelles sont les raisons de cette manif
et par les raisons de cette
manifestation est de protester contre la
politique du gouvernement
particulièrement contre la vente des
avions allaient bien et je veux dire que
cette manifestation n'est pas contre le
peuple français que nous savons mais
seulement contre la politique du
gouvernement français et je crois que le
peuple français la majorité du peuple
français est tout à fait en accord
en accord avec la majorité du peuple
américain qui ont qu à ce moment il faut
aider israël qui a été attaqué par les
gouvernements par les pays arabes qui
ont dit qu'ils ne seront pas satisfaits
avant que israel ne sera pas détruit ira
passer manifestation le porte-parole de
la maison blanche déclaré que l'accueil
réservé par son gouvernement à monsieur
pompidou serait à la hauteur de l'amitié
franco américaine
cette manifestation tout de même a été
un peu moins agressive qu'on aurait pu
le craindre
et il est vrai que depuis 48 heures les
journaux américains donnait des conseils
à leurs concitoyens en leur demandant d'
accueillir le président français avec
courtoisie et corrections les américains
suivent d'autre part avec intérêt la une
réunion qui se tient à paris depuis hier
sous la présidence de monsieur valéry
giscard d'estaing c'est la réunion des
six ministres des finances des pays du
marché commun en effet cette réunion a
pour but d'examiner un plan allemand
dont le but est de donner par étape une
monnaie à l'europe de créer une monnaie
européenne voilà pourquoi les américains
suivent cela avec beaucoup d'attention
les journaux américains accordent aussi
une grande place aux événements du
moyen-orient en particulier à l'attentât
commis hier par un commando palestinien
contre un car de touristes américains
qui circulait en jordanie
une touriste a été tué et trois autres
blessés d'autre part à la suite de
l'attentât contre l'avion coronado de la
suisse air le gouvernement suisse a pris
des mesures qui aboutissent en fait à
fermer ses frontières aux arabes les
suisses ne délivrerons plus de visas à
des arabes que pour des raisons
humanitaires ou précise le communiqué
officiel
lorsque d'importants intérêts suisses
seront en jeu de nombreuses compagnies
aériennes en particulier en allemagne et
en grande bretagne ont pris des mesures
de sécurité
ça n'a d'ailleurs pas empêché les
employés de la compagnie anglaise bo
assez de se mettre en grève ils
boycottent désormais tous les avions des
huit compagnies arabes qui font escale à
londres
quant au président de la fédération
internationale des pilotes de ligne hta
suédois qui se nomme aulas forsberg
il veut saisir les nations unies pour
obtenir des garanties contre la
piraterie aérienne faute de quoi ils
menacent de déclencher une grève de 24
heures de tous les pilotes du monde en
france on va reparler du plat garaudy
roger garaudy vous vous en souvenez a
été l'accusé du dernier congrès du parti
communiste français qui s'est tenue à
nanterre il a été exclu du comité
central exclu du bureau politique et
malgré cela il refuse de se taire notre
confrère le figaro publie ce matin les
extraits d'un nouveau livre de roger
garaudy un livre qui s'intitule toute la
vérité ne se garent audi reprend et
précise les critiques qu'il a déjà
formulé contre l'union soviétique
j'accuse dit il
dirigeant soviétique de ternir par leur
comportement la belle et juste images du
socialisme monsieur garaudy cependant
affirme son attachement au parti
communiste français
mais on peut naturellement se demander
maintenant s'il ne risque pas d'en être
exclu totalement
une nouvelle assez étonnante nous est
venue de londres ce matin en effet une
anglaise de 34 ans sera peut-être la
première femme qui aura un bébé
éprouvette il s'agit en somme d'une
expérience de fécondation artificielle
mais hors du corps dans un tube à essai
elle a été tentée par le directeur d'une
clinique anglaise ça s'est déjà fait en
france c'est le professeur thibault à
jouy en josas sur les animaux
principalement sur des lapines ou sur
des vaches mais c'est la première fois
qu'une tentative de ce genre est fait
sur une femme alors rosie morel vous
avez demandé aux professeurs les terres
qui est chef du service d'endocrinologie
de la reproduction à l'hôpital necker de
nous apporter quelques lumières je
voulais oui je crois qu'il faut préciser
qu'une fois que cette fécondation aura
été fait dans le tube à essai l'ovule
fécondé sera un réimplantés dans
l'utérus de la femme et que la grossesse
poursuivra normalement et il n'a y pas
question de faire venir le bébé
totalement à l'extérieur du corps cecily
cette technique présente certainement de
grand avantage à quelle forme de
stérilité s'adresse-t-elle ne s'adresse
essentiellement aux stérilité par
obstruction des trompes et est la
différence avec la relativement
classique assimilation artificiel la
différence est énorme dans
l'insémination dit artificielle équine
est artificielle que par ses moyens on
porte le sperme au delà de l'obstacle du
col de la matrice la l'obstacle au
contraire ici dans le cas de ce type
tower de edwards dans ce cas l'obstacle
et hubert c'est à dire dans la trompe et
il n'est pas possible de faire franchir
cet obstacle
autrement que par une fécondation dans
un dans le vert le faire franchir cet
obstacle aux spermatozoïdes et aussi à
l'ovule
l'obus est prélevée sur l'eau vers même
de la patiente au moment de l'ovulation
et qu'est ce qui se passe ensuite quelle
est la technique utilisée pour la
fécondation la technique que présente
pas mal de difficultés ou
imaginez bien les deux principales
difficultés c'est d'abord de recueillir
un novice qui soit réellement mur c'est
à dire qu'il ya une affaire de
synchronisation qui est très bien
réalisée par la nature et qui devraient
pouvoir être réalisé aussi dans l'espèce
humaine grâce des nouvelles techniques
la deuxième c'est que il est difficile
une fois l'eau vulnit in vitro de le
faire aborder par le spermatozoïde est
de le faire pénétrer par le
spermatozoïde et là il ya eu une idée
géniale d'edward qui a consisté à
prendre du liquide de follicules humain
c'est à dire de cette cavité dans lequel
l'a vu les contenus et de l'ajouter au
milieu de ces roms et dans ces
conditions le spermatozoïde pénètre à
l'intérieur de l'ovocyte
il ya une question qui vient tout de
suite à l'esprit supposons qu'une femme
est un ovaire mal formés et qu'elle ne
pondent pas du tout devait peut-on
imaginer de féconder avec semences de
son mari l'ovule d'une autre femme
l'enfant serait tout au moins celui de
son mari si nous le sien oui bien
entendu cela peut s'imaginer cette fois
ci les obstacles ne sont plus tellement
physique
ils sont essentiellement moreau je crois
que penser de même aux actes en fait que
celui de la fécondation de l'hétéro
insémination 6 public et condamné je
crois par le vatican qui est condamnée
par le vatican comme de même que la
technique des douars de steak toc est
également condamnée par le vatican
est ce qu'un allant plus loin on ne peut
pas imaginer une fécondation extérieur
au corps d'un ovule et des
spermatozoïdes de deux personnes données
et que leurs enfants seraient fabriqués
par une autre femme chez lequel cet
effet cordes et serait implantée c'est
un peu le meilleur des mondes mais on
l'a réalisé sur l'animal c'est pour ça
qu'il faut se demander si ce serait
possible à jour sur leurs ce sera
vraisemblablement possible en effet sur
l'homme puisque qui volent à réaliser
sur le lapin et il est vraisemblable que
ce sera possible
mais mais il ya des dangers ont tout
cela est certainement merveilleux mais
c'est aussi un peu effrayant nous allons
parler du temps maintenant et le temps
c'est toujours le mauvais temps en
montagne ça signifie encore des risques
d'avalanche pour toute la moitié nord de
la france cela veut dire des inondations
car partout les rivières continue de
monter situation difficile dans la seine
et marne où le loin elle
je m'en chante i de son lit du côté de
morez et de saint mammès quatre routes
départementales
un peu plus loin c'est la marne qui
déborde les affluent de la seine monte
conséquence la scène monte aussi à paris
elle atteint ce matin 4 mètre 95 soit 15
cm de plus qui y est si le mouvement
continue on prévoit cinq mètres 40
vendredi et peut-être même si m à la fin
de ce mois
à partir de cet après midi
mais cette prévision rassurante pourrait
être compromise par la pluie
la pluie qui tombe en abondance dans le
haut doubs dans la région de pontarlier
des violentes tempêtes à la neige et du
verglas à l'appui il ne manquait plus
bien sûr que les inondations pour que le
bilan climatique actuel de la région des
pays de la loire soit complet en effet à
vent de noroît aidant il a beaucoup plu
ces derniers jours et la loire à mort
onze mois de l'année n'a pas failli à la
tradition février dans son moi favori
celui où elle fait ses caprices celui où
elle résout ses complexes de fleuves
dans et bona ainsi il a quitté son lit
envahissant les paires et les jardins de
la vallée aux environs d'ancenis de
drains et de lire et la patrie deux
joues h1 du pellet quant au village des
fourneaux il est entièrement baignée par
les eaux et les riverains qui en ont
bien vu d'autres ont pris eux aussi
leurs habitudes d'hiver à savoir les
traversées en bateau qui pour offrir de
belles images dont pourtant rien de
romantique et cela pour conduire les
enfants à l'école à l'ére travail et
faire les courses en essayant comme on
dit de ne pas oublier les allumettes
hier matin aux alentours de 9 heures la
vieille tour des barbacane à domfront
s'est écroulé les plus abondantes de ces
derniers jours avaient fini de saper les
murs de soutènement construite au
moyen-âge elle faisait partie de la
ceinture qui entourait jadi domfront ce
sont plus de 400 tonnes de pierres et de
terre qui ont glissé sur la chaussée
par chance l'effondrement a fait peu de
dégâts matériels est chanceux plus inouï
encore aucun blessé en effet chaque jour
de la semaine 250 enfants attendent au
pied de cette tour le car de ramassage
scolaire 20 minutes seulement s'étaient
écoulées depuis le départ des derniers
lorsque le vieux monument s'est abattue
failli oublier la caméra
l'avalanche qui s'est produite ce matin
en suisse a fait presque autant de
victimes que celle de val d'isère cela
s'est produit à 5h30 ce matin dans une
zone militaire à reckingen dans le
valais à une vingtaine de kilomètres de
brig sur la haute vallée du rhône
l'avalanche enseveli des chalets où
dormaient des militaires qui
participaient à des manoeuvres
une quarantaine de personnes se sont
retrouvées bloquées sous une masse de
neige qui atteignaient parfois dix
mètres de hauteur est actuellement le
bilan est de 5 morts 24 disparus et 19
blessés
l'institut d'étude de la neige de davos
avait donné l' alerte aux avalanches
il y a déjà plusieurs jours mais cet
avertissement vous le voyez n'a pas
suffi à empêcher la catastrophe
en france aussi des dangers d'avalanches
persiste et surtout à val d'isère et à
tignes et à l'instant nous apprenons que
cette nationale 202 qui relie bourg
saint maurice à val d'isère et que nous
poser je sais avait réussi à dégager
dimanche matin après une première coulée
de neige qu'ils avaient obstrué dans la
nuit de vendredi à samedi
et bien cette nationale est de nouveau
coupée sur 200 mètres par une avalanche
il ya eu une coulée de neige la neige
est maintenant haute de 4 mètres
il n'y a aucune victime mais tignes et
val d'isère se trouve de nouveau isolée
l'avalanche a emporté sur son passage
des câbles souterrains et les deux
stations je tourne ainsi privés de
téléphone
les installations électriques ont
également souffert les services déposé
chaussée sans voix depuis plusieurs
heures à rétablir la circulation mais le
mauvais temps qui sévit sur la région
rend les opérations très difficile
ce soir à 21h informations première vous
présentera le dossier complet de la
catastrophe de val d'isère et des
dangers d'avalanches en montagne
au cours de l'émission d'actualité le
quatrième mardi
et pourtant malgré tout cela le ski
continue surtout aux états unis il est
vrai patrick chapuis pour les membres de
l'équipe de france de ski
nous allons faire le point de la coupe
du monde de ski mais d'abord une
nouvelle de rugby un retour sympathique
oui c'est une bonne nouvelle pour tous
les sportifs sur le retour de walter
spanghero en équipe de france vous
souvenez que en début de saison où
walter avait eu un différend et hull
pardon un différend avec les
sélectionneurs ce différend s'est
arrangé puisque walter a rencontré noël
beaudry la des principaux sélectionneur
et il a été décidé que le 7 mars
walter spanghero serait le capitaine de
l'équipe de france b qui sera opposé au
case de france b occase de galber
excusez moi c'est certainement un pas
vers le retour de sport gayraud dans le
tournoi des cinq nations en ski vous
nous en parler dit laisse après les
épreuves de jackson hole il faut faire
le point sur la coupe du monde
il semble bien que la coupe ne puisse
plus échapper maintenant car de france
quatre chemins en effet a pris 4 points
et c'est lui vraisemblement qui
succédera à jean-claude killy
son avance est désormais de six points
sur patrick russel et l'hystérie
l'italien gustavo tony
chez les femmes la coupe du monde ne
devrait pas échapper non plus l
française puisque c'est michel jacquot
qui est actuellement en tête ce soir au
cirque d'hiver le titre national des
poids plume est en jeu feliz brami sera
le challenger de daniel vermande r nous
avons suivi l'entraînement de félice
brami à la salle filippi c'est à la
salle filippi de neuilly que félix
barbie se prépare sacs de sable pour
commencer et ensuite une bonne séance
sur le ring face sparring partner brami
a travaillé sa vitesse et aussi son
souffle car la meilleure chose qu'ils
possèdent ce soir face à revers manders
et le pousser le combat au delà des dire
au plus
en effet vers mende et qui est un ancien
champion amateur n'a jamais boxé plus de
dix reprises
or le combat de ce soir est prévu en dix
ans
brahmi qui a maintenant 30 ans a besoin
de fait un bon combat ce soir deux
victoires récentes face au champion de
paris henri les eu et au biarrot paul
roux ont fait oublier le chaos
retentissant qu'il avait subi un premier
round contre le cubain jose le gras et
philippe filippi compte beaucoup sur son
prix le combat de ce soir entre brami et
vermandel devrait être serré violent
brahmi est un battant et la façon dont
il boxe ici contre sa propre image et
bien caractéristique de son style
attention seulement à ne pas casser la
glace
il paraît que cela porte malheur voilà
j'en ai terminé
jacqueline alexandre c'est à vous
maintenant et comme chaque mardi vous
nous présenter d'abord la chronique
juridique ou effectivement et
aujourd'hui elle et elle concerne
particulièrement les gens qui vont se
marier et même ceux qui sont mariés
depuis très peu de temps je crois depuis
deux ans devant la loi que signifie
exactement le mot mariage
un reportage de christiane delacroix
bonheur rayonne sur les visages de ceux
qui veulent vivre à de leur existence
le mariage c'est un engagement auquel la
loi a donné une force particulière
comment une avocate à la cour de paris
nous apporte des précisions
une première question qui peut
surprendre tout le monde ne peut pas se
marier
quelles sont les conditions requises
mais d'abord il faut être pleinement
capable c'est à dire pleinement
conscients enfin tout au moins sur le
plan juridique je ne parle pas bien
entendu du plan sentimental
d'autre part il ya également une
question d'âge
un garçon doit avoir 18 ans révolus et
une fille 15 ans alors dans le cas de
roméo et juliette même si les capulet et
montaigu avait été d'accord il n'aurait
pas pu se marier
maintenant je crois que roméo et
juliette n'aurait pas pu alors ça ça je
crois que c'est très regrettable
pas seulement sur le plan juridique mais
pour d'une façon générale je crois que
nous aurions beaucoup perdu pour en
venir à des problèmes actuels je crois
que beaucoup de personnes ne sont pas
conscientes de l'importance d'un contrat
de mariage
c'est à dire je crois que la plupart des
jeunes quand ils se dirigent vers la
mairie
c'est d'ailleurs assez compréhensible
ils sont euphoriques
une pause et de rien et au fond il se
demande de ne vous voit pas très bien
quoi peut servir un contrat de mariage
je suis persuadé qu'aucun d'entre eux
n'y a songé ou alors à moins d'une
minorité
oui et c'est une erreur à mon avis de
leur part parce que très souvent il est
vrai beaucoup mieux d'avoir été voir un
avocat avant leur mariage
bon ne pas avoir à aller le voir après
parce que même s'ils ne possèdent rien
il peut se poser par la suite le
problème de l'administration de leurs
biens je suppose que le garçon et la
fille travaille sur un salaire et puis
peut-être aussi des économises
achèteront maison de campagne ou un
petit appartement tout simplement et est
alors à à chaque moment de leur vie
il se posera le problème de
l'administration de leurs biens et par
conséquent le choix du contrat est au
contraire très important même
aujourd'hui même s'ils ne sont pas
passés devant un à terre ils sont soumis
à un régime matrimonial
oui de la communauté réduite aux acquêts
cétacés le sait le régime légal et
depuis la loi du 13 juillet 1965
ils ont même la possibilité dans un
délai de deux ans après le mariage
ils ont la possibilité de changer de
contrat et s'ils n'ont pas passé de
passer cette fois ci un nouveau contrat
celui de leur choix tout contrat prévoit
la répartition des charges du ménage
oui mais c'était vous êtes quand même un
principe qui est d'ordre légal
c'est-à-dire que chaque époux
participent contribuer en fonction de
ses possibilités respectives enfin ça ça
repose pour l'instant à titre principal
sur le mac
quels sont les pouvoirs de la femme sur
ses biens propres et bien maintenant
elle les administrent librement et elles
en disposent librement
quel que soit le contrat à oui ça
maintenant la femme à ce droit qui était
qui quels sont les différents régimes
matrimoniaux et bien alors ça je suis
bien évidemment obligé de vous lui
expliquez d'une façon très simple les
régimes principaux sont les suivants
vous avez d'abord le régime légal qui
est un régime de communauté réduite aux
acquêts
c'est à dire que chaque époux conserve
en propre tous les biens meubles et
immeubles qu'il possédait avant le
mariage
et alors ils se forment une communauté
qui composaient uniquement des biens
qu'ils auront acquis pendant le mariage
à titre onéreux je ne parle pas des
héritages et alors cette communauté est
administré par le mari
d'autre part vous avez un autre régime
que l'on peut prendre par contrat et
c'est celui-là séparation bien c'est
celui qui choisit d'ailleurs par
enchaînera par tous les commerçants
chaque époux conserve alors à titre
personnel tous les biens qu'il possédait
avant le mariage et chaque époux
continuera à administrer et à posséder
seul ses biens personnels n'y a
absolument pas de communauté alors vous
avez un troisième régime
ensuite on ne connaît pas très bien et
le garde des sceaux l'avait qualifié du
plus futuriste des régimes matrimoniaux
alors c'est le régime qui est pratiqué
dans un certain nombre de pays
scandinaves et qui est le suivant c'est
une séparation de biens
pendant la vie des époux chacun conserve
ses biens personnels
et puis alors au moment de la 10
mission toujours ou par décès ou par
divorce on fait le bilan on compte
l'enrichissement du patrimoine des époux
et alors cet enrichissement est partagée
en deux il ya quelqu'un que vous voulez
ce qu'on pourrait appeler une une
cagnotte
alors au fond ça présente les avantages
de la séparation de biens
puisque chacun pousse à son indépendance
mais à mon avis par contre ça ne
présente pas les inconvénients puisque
alors cette fois ci la femme participera
d'ailleurs d'où le nom de participation
aux acquêts la femme participera à
l'enrichissement du ménage et au fond ce
jeu peut-être est-ce le régime de
l'avenir passons des conseils
matrimoniaux à ceux de gérants vidal ans
à la bourse de paris
je ne sais pas si c'est pour accueillir
monsieur pompidou aux états unis
quoi qu'il en soit la bourse de new york
était très ferme hier et les valeurs
américaines à paris sont également bien
qu on a remarqué la hausse de la royal
dutch qui se poursuit alors que la
française des pétroles dans le même
secteur pétrolier a plutôt du plomb dans
l aile et il y a